what else should i say
[Laughter]
[Music]
we've been dating for eight and a half
years honestly i'm the one who does most
of the cooking i would say that i am the
better cook but actually george is a
great cook before jasmine i did cook a
lot when i was living on my own i would
cook pretty much every night and i do
really enjoy cooking he doesn't really
measure things but it's still really
delicious that's what makes me a good
cook oh that's what makes me a good cook
too yeah go team go team i think it's
gonna be so easy to guess what george
made if you don't get it right let's add
some steaks to this
sushi for a week that's that's good for
you good luck babe all right oh whoa so
to make the competition more fair i've
chosen three ingredients that each chef
must use which are udon kimchi and
butter because these three ingredients
already make up a very simple recipe
that i actually enjoy i also feel like
it puts a parameter around what they can
make george has some pretty tough
competition first there's katie who i
cook with often i've eaten a lot of the
dishes she's made not a single one that
i don't like mimo she comes from an
extraordinary pastry background her
dishes are bound to look flawless george
has worked with these ingredients very
very often i really expect him to
hit it out of the park
[Music]
today i'm making jasmine a kimchi udon
noodle stir-fry let's go ahead and begin
so i'm starting with a little bit of
olive oil because i'm going to fry some
garlic so wait for that to get to
temperature i'm just going to add in my
garlic now i'm just going to lightly not
even brown them jasmine and i are both
huge garlic lovers and now that the
garlic is pretty much transparent i'm
just gonna add in this kimchi and i'm
using tong so that i'm only grabbing the
kimchi itself and i'm saving the juice
for later so i know jasmine loves kimchi
and she loves a lot of it and now i'm
going to add in a little bit more oil
and my beef brisket i chose beef brisket
for this dish because i wanted to add a
little bit of meat to it and i
personally love beef briskets i'm a
little bit concerned that i'm going to
make a frankenstein dish for jasmine
because she grew up eating korean food i
didn't in a way i don't want to take it
too far from what she's used to but i do
want to kind of give it my own natural
splash so the beef is a little bit pink
now which means it's time to move on to
the next stage now i'm adding in the
corn i don't know if this is a very
traditional korean recipe but it just
adds that really great balance to the
dish because it has a sweetness to it
and jasmine loves corn so now that we've
got the three main ingredients all ready
and cooked up we're just going to add in
the wet ingredients so that's going to
be my kupi mayo here the koopa mayo is a
little bit different from just regular
mayo it's a japanese mayonnaise which
means it's a little bit sweeter it's a
little bit tarter the next thing i'm
going to add is the gochujang gochujang
is a korean chili paste it's really
delicious i'm also going to be adding
this butter i'm not going to use the
entire thing she doesn't really love
butter and then the last of the wet
ingredients is going to be the leftover
kimchi juice so this is what we saved
earlier i'm just going to give this a
nice little stir now i got a pack of the
frozen uda noodles and the udon noodles
are actually already cooked so you don't
need to necessarily cook them but what i
like to do is i like to just thaw them
in a bowl of water and that way the
noodles are going to separate we're just
going to let the udon noodles cook for a
little bit and once they're ready i'm
going to give this a little bit of a try
[Music]
definitely needs a good bit more
gochujang but i think after this it
should be good i'm not sure if i'm going
to win this guys so right now i'm adding
in some crushed black pepper because i
feel like the dish needed a little bit
of that spice that wasn't coming from
the gochujang taste test number two
oh yes so next up we're going to add in
the shredded mozzarella cheese and this
is more of a new
korean ingredient i don't think that
mozzarella cheese is necessarily very
traditional either while i'm waiting for
this mozzarella cheese to melt i'm just
going to add in this sliced cali to give
it that nice little pop of color this is
coming along nicely the cheese is
starting to get nice and melty now the
tricky part is going to be when i plate
it because i am an awful later all right
here comes plating time baby i got this
oh my god my mom raised a winner no she
raised a loser oh mom you still love me
right some finishing touches with a
little bit more cheese just on top
because i kind of flipped everything
upside down a little bit more scallion
and lastly this is very optional i'm
just adding in a little bit of toasted
sesame seeds and that is my dish
[Music]
today i'm making udon gyoza i think that
jasmine might like know that i'm
attracted to this it looks fun to make
so she might know it's me i'm gonna put
all of my sauces and seasoning together
first so that is some sesame oil we've
got our oyster sauce here which is
something jasmine uses a lot i'm gonna
do some soy sauce
some garlic jasmine loves garlic and
then i've got some ginger and some salt
i'm just eyeballing that and
this is potato starch which is just
gonna act like keep it all together i
found a bunch of recipes on japanese
websites and i found one on bonapetite
i'm putting my own twist on it so we'll
see how it turns out i'm gonna give this
a taste just to see if i got the
flavoring right
[Music]
a lot of potatoes
i feel like this was lacking in ginger
flavor and i think i could do even a
little bit more garlic so i'm going to
do pork it's kind of based off a pork
gyoza that she made for our tasty time
to cook go check out that video and then
i'm adding some green onions and now i'm
adding the kimchi and i'm going to
eyeball this and now we have our udon
noodles so that's two
out of the three ingredients we're
making the filling of what would be in
gyoza and then the udon noodles are kind
of acting like the wrapper and then last
thing we're gonna do is add an egg i
think she's gonna like this i'm also
sorry to anyone who's made this before
and i'm not doing it right all right i
think this is looking good i hope it
tastes good so i am gonna get kind of
like a golf ball size in my hand here
and make some patties all right my
patties are ready i'm gonna take a
little bit of oil what i don't want is
these to be super greasy i feel like
jasmine would be like ting bad we're
gonna let that oil heat up i think the
oil is hot enough but i'm putting it in
oh yes it kind of reminds me of making
like a vegetable fritter or any kind of
like potato fritter and i like it to be
nice and thin and crispy looking good
i'm gonna cover these guys for five
minutes and let them cook there's a
chance i turned the heat up too high on
these guys
oh okay great we got some color they're
like little burners i'm gonna let this
go for three more minutes these guys are
done so i'm going to put them on my
plate they're really big i think they're
a little bigger than i initially
intended okay i'm going to move on to my
sauce now for the sauce i'm going to be
making like a kimchi butter sauce yeah i
don't think that jasmine does like
butter why did she choose it i mean i
have some kimchi paste here i'm going to
add that in i'm going to turn my heat
down because i don't want to brown the
butter jasmine will definitely know it's
me if it has brown butter because i love
brown butter and i'm going to add some
soy sauce
we're going to add some honey for
sweetness
now i'm gonna add in the garlic chili
oil
salty i think i'm gonna add a little bit
more butter and i'm gonna do a little
bit more of the kimchi paste because i
feel like it's bringing in the spice and
i want a little more spice i think
that's going to be good i feel like a 7
out of 10 of confidence that's pretty
high i'm going to transfer this to my
bowl and we're almost done oh it's so
cute we've got the patties on a plate
i'm going to put the sauce in the middle
for our final plating and then i'm going
scallions it's going back and forth but
i want this to look sort of pretty i
always love like a cracked fresh pepper
on like anything i'm eating and if i did
that jasmine would like a thousand
percent note did george use black pepper
she's definitely gonna think that's me
[Music]
today i'll be making okonomiyaki i know
jasmine pretty well we eat lunch
together a lot so i feel like i know
what she likes and what she doesn't like
i know george is jasmine's boyfriend and
he gets like the inside scoop as the
culinary expert think i know better
let's get started first i'm gonna add
two eggs to this bowl and i'm gonna
whisk it well then i'm gonna add my
chicken stock
and now i'm gonna add my flour i'm gonna
add some salt
and i'm now gonna fold my other
ingredients i'm gonna start with my
carrots and then i'm gonna add the
cabbage and now i'm gonna add my udon
noodles
and my kimchi i eat kimchi a lot and
cabbage but the other ones i don't cook
with that often now i'm gonna add some
oil to my pan and i'm gonna be generous
because i don't want it to stick and now
i'm gonna add some butter for some
flavor in here i know jasmine loves
butter so
she's gonna love that now that that's
ready we're gonna add our batter make
sure it's beautiful
and cook that until it's crispy on the
bottom and then i will flip it honestly
speaking jasmine likes a lot of things
she's very
open to trying different foods i am like
90 sure she's gonna like this so i think
it's time to flip because
it looks like it's set i'm gonna use
this plate
put it back on there that way it cooks
beautiful
[Music]
i know traditionally this dish doesn't
have kimchi and udon so i just switched
up some ingredients in order to include
jasmine's favorite ingredients in here
it smells so good if jasmine doesn't
like this i'm gonna be very hurt first
we're going to top it with the
okonomiyaki sauce and i'm going to be
pretty generous with this guy and then
we're going to top it with cupid mayo
and then we have a dehydrated pork it's
a little bit candied gives it a
different layer of flavor then we have
some fur kake then we have some
scallions and it's all done i hope
jasmine likes this i will be hurt if she
picks someone else's and not mine i
think she might have an idea that this
is mine because she knows i like baking
and this is sort of like a pancake but
we'll see
[Music]
oh my gosh i'm so excited thank you
mmm
i think it's george
but right off the bat green onions i do
it just like this i add corn in my
stir-fry noodles and i'm seeing some
thinly sliced beef it reminds me of
korean barbecue he knows i love korean
bbq there's mozzarella cheese he knows i
love that combination
[Music]
you can't tell me it's not george
this tastes delicious this is pretty
much exactly how i would make mine with
maybe a little less cream and a little
less cheese this is exactly how george
would make it how could it not be him
good job babe good job
[Music]
thank you so much
wow
that's creative wow right off the bat i
have no clue who made this
maybe it's katie
um
good job very good is it pork in there
that's very nice the noodles are nice
and bouncy good crisp my gut is telling
me katie she developed tasty recipes for
a very long time and that requires her
to get really really creative this is a
very delicious dish i'm very surprised
that with those three ingredients you
were able to conjure up something like
this
thank you
wow
holy moly this reminds me of okonomiyaki
okay i gotta try this right off the bat
i think this is nemo because she comes
from a pastry background so she's used
to making things look um phenomenal
[Music]
mmm it's delightful very good i love
pork so stand by my final answer i think
it's you memo i think i've gotten three
amazing recipes today that have been
super creative and out of the box i
think this one is george's
[Music]
he knows i always complain about any
kimchi dish not having enough kimchi and
like this has a lot of kimchi juice and
the corn like that's very telltale sign
i guess i know we're best
maybe i know all of you guys the best
[Laughter]
i think this one is katie's
i
oh
i know my friends well i'm so happy come
on out mimo
oh my god i think it's really special
because when i'm cooking i always try to
infuse my personality my identity into
my foods and i feel like i really saw
that today it was like very much proven
by your dishes my favorite i'm not gonna
lie it's this one
[Applause]
why did you choose butter i love butter
oh okay oh okay i said she doesn't like
the flavor of butter
she doesn't really love butter butter
yeah i don't think that jasmine does
look better pretty sushi for a week
oh yes
[Music]
you